[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8 soit
dit ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
quatorzième numéro une édition spéciale
vacances de noël tout de suite le
sommaire de ce jeudi 20 décembre les
enfants l'attend avec impatience vos
maisons et sapins sont décorées pour sa
venue proches le père noël sera avec
nous en plateau et répondra aux
questions des petits yvelinois l'espace
richard accueille de nouveaux habitants
de 7,5 cm les playmobil vous raconte
l'histoire pendant toutes les vacances
scolaires les châteaux aux yvelinois
fait aussi noël nous verrons nous ferons
un tour des différentes animations
proposées dans ces demeures d'exception
les célèbres figurines en plastique
playmobil ont investi l'espace richaud à
versailles du 22 décembre au 6 janvier
l'exposition l'histoire en playmobil il
vous propose un voyage dans le temps à
travers différents tableaux et
reconstitutions un montage de jules grün
ville une entrée dans le monde des
playmobil pour expliquer l'histoire aux
enfants l'espace richaud a donné carte
blanche à deux artistes et leurs petites
figurines
l'un d'entre eux est venue avec ses
trois camions remplis 30 mètres cubes de
playmobil donc il doit y avoir 12 scènes
plus grosse scène centrale et au fond et
à mesure on passe de la préhistoire aux
romains aux gaulois au moyen-âge
la louis xiv les pirates ont mal est un
petit peu tôt jusqu'à l'époque actuelle
jusqu'à l'espace des reconstitutions de
scènes appelé diorama mais aussi des
photos qui rappellent des tableaux
célèbres
j'ai trouvé dans le playmobil le casting
idéal pour moi pour pouvoir raconter des
choses en fait sérieuse mais aux enfants
des enfants qui ne souhaiteront pas et
interprète facilement les scènes
représentées faire la bataille avec les
gaulois sont les gaulois soeur le sas
nous on a vu des arènes et des mammouths
des serpents et des tigres à dents de
sabre
[Musique]
organisée pas touchés elvis presley les
beatles le cirque l'histoire culturelle
est aussi largement présente
c'est assez impressionnant il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de mobiles plus que
dans ta chambre
et ça prend vis c'est chouette chacun
peut donc y retrouver son histoire nous
à la rédaction nous avons identifié
notre figurines et autres expositions à
visiter en famille dans le monde des
caps là cette fois le pôle culturel la
lanterne de rambouillet propose de
découvrir ou redécouvrir des monuments
européens et nationaux en cap là
jusqu'au 26 janvier
des ateliers de construction gratuits
seront également présentés petite
exclusivité de la ville des créations
uniques à partir des monuments de
rambouillet c'est une personne bien
particulière qui m'a rejoint sur ce
plateau avec son bonnet rouge et sa
barbe blanche
il nous fait l'honneur de venir à
quelques jours de sa grande distribution
père noël bonjour bonjour est ce que les
petits événements ont été sages cette
année alors à priori la plupart d'entre
eux oui je mets quand même encore sous
surveillance quelques jeunes enfants ils
sont quand même plus ou moins sage avec
les parents donc le message que je veux
leur passé soyez bien sage rester sur la
liste des enfants sages que le père noël
viennent vous apportez vos cadeaux
valeurs on a rencontré quelques-uns en
espérant qu'ils soient sur la liste des
enfants sages on commence avec chloé qui
a 7 ans quel âge as-tu
alors je suis très très très très vieux
tellement vieux que je ne me rappelle
même plus mon âge
or mais c'est mais je suis toujours
toujours rester jeune et je m'occupe
toujours des enfants sages
donc voilà ma petite puce manon 6 ans à
une autre question pour vous l'amour
bien sûr j'ai une amoureuse c'est la
mère noël à la mère noël elle
m'accompagne elle s'occupe de moi
elle fait en sorte que je sois toujours
en forme pour pouvoir venir livrer les
cadeaux
le jour de noël là on sort de la vie
personnelle avec julia trois ans
pippa mann qu'abbiati d'état ou alors g8
rennes magique mais rennes sont magiques
ils sont huit
ils sont adorables gentil et grâce à eux
je peux faire la tournée et distribué
tous les cadeaux dans tous les foyers à
tous les enfants sages
alors justement raphaël qui a 5 ans pose
des questions sur ce cadeau qui compte
quand il était ado alors comment je
construis les cadeaux et bien c'est d'en
montrer très grand atelier est en fait
j'ai les lutins qui construisent les
cadeaux toute l'année et après derrière
qui m'aident à charger le traîneau quand
je viens faire la distribution des
cadeaux aux enfants
je crois que emi à une question sur ses
lutins elle a six ans combien as-tu des
mutins alors ma petite puce et les
lutins j'en ai des centaines j'en ai des
centaines et des centaines parce qu'il
ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de travail
à faire toute l'année pour construire
tous les jeux les poupées les peluches
que je vous amène le jour de noël
centaines de lutte ans a fait beaucoup
de vélo j'ai commun a alors là encore on
a un très grand atelier et on a
également une très très grande maison
pour tous les lutins de manière à ce qu
effectivement ils soient au plus près
pour venir travailler tous les jours et
construire l'ensemble des jouets alors
une dernière question du petit camille
c'est
est ce que tu peut m'apporter des
playmobil pour noël ce qui plaît tant
alors petite camille évidemment bien sûr
je peux amener des pertes des playmobil
pour noël toujours comme je l'aï dit au
début
à la condition que tu reste bien dans la
liste des enfants sages donc avec papa
et maman il faut vraiment bien écouter
également être toujours mignonne et
effectivement je pourrais amener des
playmobil pour noël
mon père noël c'est bon on est prêts
pour l'année du 20e 25 absolument aucune
inquiétude
les le chargement du traîneau va bientôt
commencer
tous les jouets sont là ils sont
fabriqués ils sont prêts et nous avons
mis les petites étiquettes pour chacun
des enfants de tout le monde
super on peut rassurer tous les enfants
remercient père noël tu es devenu cionet
plateau c'est moi c'est moi merci de
m'avoir invité ça m'a permis de
m'adresser aux petits-enfants yvelinois
et c'est pas tous les jours j'en ai non
plus cette occasion donc merci à vous
très bien je souhaite une bonne petite
tribu sion et faites attention avec les
cheminées aucun souci je vais rester
très prudent sortez vos patins à glace
la ville de guyancourt installe une
patinoire pour la première fois 162
mètres carrés au pavillon waldeck
rousseau a foulé jusqu'au 31 décembre
vous pourrez même retrouvé des
équipements spécifiques comme des
chaises luge l'espace philippe noiret
aussi à sa patinoire du 22 décembre au 5
janvier
vous pouvez consulter le programme et
les horaires d'ouverture sur le site de
la ville des clayes-sous-bois comme tous
les ans le signer cette d'elancourt
propose pour noël son festival disney le
tour de l'ensemble de sa programmation
avec patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
alors vacances de noël approchant oblige
d'une grosse programmation cette semaine
au ciné sets avec deux sorties
nationales
le blockbuster de chez warner aquaman en
2d 3d vfb au donc sur nos écrans cette
semaine est aussi le dernier disney me
retourne mariko pils la suite attendue
les aventures de mary poppins plein
d'autres films de qualité
pupilles de génériques reprenons cette
semaine brain rhapsodie pour les fans de
queen et aussi les autres qui
connaissent pas la vie de freddie
mercury toujours super vfb aux robins
des bois le grand bain pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vu les disney de noël tous les
ans on fait une petite opération on
passe des vieux disney non classé cette
semaine c'est cendrillon et monstres et
compagnie
astérix toujours et secrets de
l'appelation magique pour les familles
le grinch aussi est ainsi défini pour
les tout petits
mimi elisa les lumières de noël dimanche
matin à 10h30 et bonne fête à tout le
monde pour cette fin d'année
[Musique]
et pourquoi ne pas passer noël au
château à choisel château de breteuil
est entièrement décorée pour l'occasion
et adapte ses animations
le chat botté cendrillon peau d'âne
l'essai de compte ont toujours leur
place avec une petite nouvelle barbe
bleue qui ouvre justement pendant les
vacances une table bien garnie et un
cabinet de curiosités représentatif du
personnage une scène de compte
élaboré par le scénographe christophe
leray toutes les rues de la visite dans
toutes les pièces toutes les cheminées
sont décorées il y a 6 sapin qui sont
répartis sur le circuit la visite
partout il ya des décors de noël et même
dehors pendant les fêtes il y à tous les
jours des vacances scolaires des comptes
à 16h30
ce sont d'habitude les contes de
perrault est bien là au lieu de trois
contes de perrault il y a deux contes de
perrault est un conte de noël il y à 2
dimanche où il n'y aura que des comptes
d'honneur
et dimanche après noël et au début début
janvier il y aura des contes de galettes
plusieurs rendez vous au château de
rambouillet une initiation jeux d'époque
et des leçons de savoir vivre dans une
reconstitution historique du saloum jeu
de la famine et bourbon penthièvre les
29 et 30 décembre dans le cadre de la
manifestation du centre des monuments
nationaux
contes et histoires mais aussi une
découverte contée du château avec une
animatrice costumes et durant toutes les
vacances
le chef le château de versailles propose
une visite spectacle le parcours du roi
des musiciens danseurs chanteurs et
comédiens vous feront vous feront vivre
le château comme à l'époque de la cour
avec un grand final à la galerie des
batailles autre manière d'occuper les
enfants pendant les vacances les stages
la ville de plaisir en proposent des
sportifs pour les enfants de 4 à 14 ans
les jeunes seront encadrés par les
éducateurs sportifs professionnels de la
ville de 24 décembre au 4 janvier
vous pouvez vous inscrire en mairie ou
sur le site internet de plaisir rubrique
espace citoyen et pour ceux qui
préfèrent les vacances plus scientifique
le laboratoire les savants fous propose
des stages de chimie à montigny le
bretonneux deux périodes possibles pour
fabriquer des balles rebondissantes ou
créer un petit de laboratoire retrouvez
la fée clochette et le capitaine crochet
au théâtre bobino à paris jusqu'au 19
janvier le spectacle musical
peter pan est sur les planches nicolas
le hérissé de nos confrères via grand
paris s'est envolée pour le pays
imaginaire
[Musique]
et si comme peter pan vous preniez la
direction du pays imaginaire inventé en
1904 sous la plume de james matthew
barrie
le petit garçon qui refuse de grandir
est en ce moment sur les planches de
bobino un spectacle musical
nous on retrouve tout l'univers et la
féerie du pays imaginaire on balaye
toute l'aventuré c'est là qu'on démarre
dans la chambre donc c'est une chambre
victorienne du début du siècle à londres
et puis ensuite on s'envole au pays
imaginaire et on arrive donc dans ce
pays où il ya des grottes la lagune des
sirènes la grotte des enfants perdus où
ils vivent
et puis ensuite le bateau pirate du
capitaine crochet avec la cabine le
master haf entre ses décors heures qui
sont très très beau cela fait 14 ans que
le comédien joue le rôle de peter pan
dans cette adaptation fidèle de l'oeuvre
originale sur scène une dizaine de
comédiens nous plonge dans ce monde
magique vous ne passerez pas à côté du
duel entre peter pan et son redoutable
ennemi le capitaine crochet un combat à
l'épée qui a demandé une certaine
pratique aux deux comédiens
ma des vraies armes c'est à dire qu'on a
une vraie vague est une vraie épée et
puis bon c'est une chorégraphie qui
réglait mais il ya toute la vie qu'il
faut y mettre
il a un côté mondain est précieux il
aime les belles choses il aime être
regardé il aime avoir des gens à son
service il est peureux oscille un côté
très enfantin finalement il l'habite au
pays imaginaire dont qui baigne dedans
dans cette magie dans cette féerie donc
ça fait aussi partie lui comme en fait
toutes ses facettes c'est ça qui est
intéressant est que moi j'ai essayé
aussi de 10 mètres sur scène c'est qu'on
puisse apercevoir un peu toutes ses
nuances qui constitue la personnalité du
personnage
un spectacle féerique qui séduira aussi
bien les plus petits comme les plus
grands
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de votre set loisirs
merci nous avoir suivis pas de numéro
pendant les vacances je vous donne
rendez vous à la rentrée
en attendant passer de bonnes fêtes sur
tv 78
[Musique]
oui
oh
[Musique]